this is a tricky question but it's up to
you if you want to answer it
navigating Hollywood agendas sometimes
what happens and I clearly don't have to
tell you this I'm sure this has happened
to you and your career but something
will happen with someone someone will
maybe it wouldn't even be burning
somebody but somebody's offended and
then they come back to you years later
as if nothing had ever happened like
your great friends or they friend you on
social media as a professional how do
you handle that do you say you know what
it's water under the bridge
are there levels some its water in the
bridge some it's please stay over there
I think I'm good others is you know what
it was a misunderstanding I'm fine I
think it's both I think some people you
can forgive and forget some people
and cannot forgive or forget there are
other people you can forgive and not
forget
so does people you can forgive and
forget forgive and not forget it depends
on what they've done if it's the kind of
betrayal from our friend but that not
only stabbed you in the back what held
the knife and twist it up a few times to
make sure that would ever trust you
trust you having them died it's not that
she wouldn't work with them again it's
called trust but verify
but I had a martial arts teacher once
and give us lessons in terms of say
teacher said you know if a man wants to
fight you run away from him as hard and
fast as you can he said but if he runs
after you and he catches you make sure
he never chase you again he said revenge
is a dish best served cold don't shout
don't scream don't it's like playing
chess he said don't be playing chess in
the checkers the checkers of the chess
game
I said play chess it's not about the
outcome it's the process - so the trail
happens all the time
betrayal rejection and this is part of
our industry it's it's that you for the
young people coming in as business XO
man and I talk all the time about this
is like they come in with dreams and
hope see nice Bret's and butts and faces
and hair and bodies and muscles and all
that stuff and we were talking yesterday
man is going into the acting to this
road so I said look up the percentage of
Astra and SAG actors in the Union the
percentage that work annually out of a
hundred percent certain number was
twenty and out of the twenty percent how
many made over $50,000 a year 5 over 10
less about 10% they go over a hundred
thousand dollars a year just deal with
those numbers you're coming in here with
hope and dreams right along with
thousands of other people that look as
good as you on the same day your coven
coming they say don't take rejection
personally but I have to get rejected
once or twice you can understand that
but suppose you're rejected every other
day for nine years
does that do to you okay something
called pain self deprecation self-doubt
and a lot of people bury those things
with the curling drugs and I did that
for a while when I first started it's
just so painful thank God I found
meditation but I see kids out here now
on the street they came here with hopes
and dreams and you're my Senate I mean
literally on the street that now there's
hope I mean there's luck and hope and
everybody's keep dreaming they should
understand the business too and the good
part about today is you're not the wait
to be discovered you can you can click
podcasts and webisodes up if I said
something relevant and you get one or
two million eyeballs guess what they
come to you
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia been
on for 10 years now right I started I
was webisodes you survey uncle dark
girls bad girls right
millions of eyeballs because a big deal
with HBO tangerine was that Sundance two
years ago a movie made with for iPhones
anybody waiting I'm waiting for them to
see how wonderful I am
these guys got tired of waiting there is
someone discover myself and they did and
guess what when they when they got that
kind of inner confidence and self that
evaluation some changed some happen I'm
good for them
you